uh were you Blown Away by the success of
Empire Diaries were you like CU that was
like the first big boom
right and I mean were your parents blown
away and I wanted to talk about your
parents and see if they they wanted you
to get in acting and be like oh you
don't you I don't know if you should do
this but they knew you were talented you
were always singing you're always doing
these things but did you were you
surprised by the the enormity of it um I
remember I knew that I was a part of
something
special I had never done a pilot episode
of anything I had tested for
pilots and so I was very
green and um and I just remember at many
group dinners after hours and and
everyone who I had admired in the
industry for a really long time who I am
lucky enough to consider friends now I
just remember
them like they had this like look of
like Christmas morning on their face
like there's something special happening
and so I didn't I didn't know what it
was but I wasn't scared I just knew that
like this was going to be fun and you
171 episodes you did more spinoffs you
did more episodes than I I did eight
well I didn't do the full ones but but
just the success of the the you know of
the series itself um you know it it's
really incredible and I know you you
feel that when you you do conventions as
well and and you know it's interesting I
feel like there was like what comicons
and conventions used to be back in the
day are very different than what they
are right now um one I think just
because more people participate in them
on both sides um from all walk it's not
just like a niche kind of genre thing um
and also like I think that this
generation of consumers of like
entertainment consumers like they want a
piece of like what they're seeing and
they want to like you know to have the
opportunity like having the all access
on like social media and seeing you know
there is no like secret version of like
you I just read like Evelyn Hugo the
seven husbands of Evelyn Hugo and it's a
wonderful book that's on your Instagram
I just posted it today yeah I noticed it
today and I was like it's so good I
finished it last night um I like it but
it's really good um but it's all old
Hollywood and so and there is no my
there's no like secret life there's you
know people make sure that they have a
connection with the viewers so but all
that to say
um it's really it is wild it it is wild
I I wouldn't say I was surprised um but
I was surprised that I was a part of it